[Music]
grace is in los angeles hi grace welcome
to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for having me dave
sure what's up
so my husband and i um we're in baby
step seven but we actually skipped baby
step five because we cannot agree
on how to execute baby step five
um
we have three small children and he does
not want to put money away for their
college because
he's concerned that
what if they don't do a four-year
college maybe we want the money more
liquid so they can use it for a trade
school or something else of that nature
they can use they can use a 529 for
trade school
you can use it for trade school but what
if well i guess he's concerned that he
gets locked in there and then what if he
just it's not locked you can take it out
there's just a penalty on you don't get
to keep all the growth tax free
you get to pay a tax on the growth you
pay a tax on the growth
but the principal you would be able to
keep
sure and you keep all the growth minus
the penalty for the tax for taking it
out not using it for education
okay and it's transferable it's
transferable to siblings
okay so
what i guess what would you suggest we
do in this situation i mean do we
find i would suggest he gets some more
some better knowledge than he has which
will lead him to a different decision
that would be helpful
well i mean he's making he's making us
he it sounds like he thinks it's stuck
in there and christina 529 you can get
two yeah there's a lot of options with
529s you can even use it for k-12
expenses so if you notice that maybe
your oldest isn't going to college you
can switch beneficiaries and use it for
k-12 use it on another one of your kids
educations there is a lot of flexibility
in it so i know it's kind of scary
because it seems so
concerning about if your kids don't go
to school but there's there's a lot you
can do with it
but worst case scenario worst case
scenario you just simply cash it out and
let's say that you had put in 50 000 and
it grew to 100 000 i'll just make up a
number that wouldn't be right but
let's just say um let's just say you
know you made fifty thousand dollars
okay you're going to pay taxes on
the 50 000 growth
or let's say you put
60 000 in and it grew to 100 that's
probably more realistic okay so you're
going to pay taxes on the growth if you
cash it in and don't use it for
education
which you would have done if it was just
in a mutual fund by the way
okay
you have to pay taxes on if you put it
in a mutual fund you have to pay taxes
on it so
you know the the only thing the 529 does
is give you tax-free growth for
education so it's a roth ira for
education in a sense mathematically so
you can cash it out you get to keep all
the money you put in
all of the growth but you have to pay
taxes on it and a penalty on it like
cashing out an ira early
what is the penalty i
think it's 15
10 or 15. 10 or 15 it used to be
it used to be 10 and then it went up and
i think it's come back down so i can't
remember but it's not
it's you you're you're gonna get to keep
some of the growth and all of the
principle
which is all you would have got i mean
you what you're gonna lose here is the
penalty
versus if you had it in mutual funds so
it's worth it
it's worth a try okay so is it better
than in like an atma yeah yeah because
an utma you're going to pay taxes on
once it gets to a certain size
okay
is what i use for my kids because 529s
weren't there when they were little
there's no such thing so let's talk
about an atma because that's a really
good discussion thank you for calling
um an atma stands for utma uniform
transfer to miners act
in no case can a minor
under
18 years old do a financial transaction
of any kind they can't have a bank
account so if you go down and open a
bank account for your kid at the local
bank it's technically not in your kid's
name
it's technically an atma it's
technically has their name on it but it
has you as the custodian
of the account
because children are not allowed to do
contracts under contract law in america
okay
so you you open a bank account you do
anything in a kid's name
16 years old you cannot you know you
can't do a contract it's not binding so
you go open a mutual fund in the kid's
name with you as the custodian that's
all an utma is now it's taxed at the
kids rate which is nothing
until the mutual fund gets big enough
that the income off of it is past their
deduction deductible
the standard deduction okay and so you
can get 10 20 000 in there before you
pay any taxes on but then you're gonna
pay taxes on it so i paid taxes on the
mutual funds that were in my kids names
once they got to a certain size the kids
did and so it ends up with less money in
the account
because i paid taxes than i would have
if it was in growing tax-free in a 529
and so there's really very little
downside of doing the 529 that's my
point that's why i was being smart i
like about it
and well so yeah you're right it sounds
like that it's a better value and then
if they just
don't go to college because my husband's
gun shy his sister had 450 000
in student loan debt and so he's very
like you're not gonna have any student
loan debt
but
you know you're going to get you're
going to get scholarships and if you
don't go to college you know you're not
going to if you drop out early or
something we don't want you wasting it
so yeah well you can pull it out
in the current environment with higher
education having lost
its shine
with the epic student loan crisis and
with how they've misbehaved during covet
like they're trying to charge full
tuition to do uh e-learning from home
and you don't even show up at the actual
location and that they want to charge
full price and people are going i don't
think i'm paying that for that
and so higher ed's kind of got a couple
black eyes right now and a lot of people
are going look there's a whole bunch of
people got a whole bunch of stupid butt
degrees that aren't useful at all and so
there's a lot of people worried about
you know maybe for your but i don't
think you ought to throw the baby out
with the bathwater i think there's a
valid
use for higher education is it for
everyone no
uh and before i get a master's degree
for 250 000 in sociology i'm gonna go
get a welding certificate and make three
times what a sociologist makes
okay
and so uh you know that's you know i'm
with people on that but this idea that
all higher ed is bad we don't believe
that right yeah i would challenge you
all to take that fear from the 450 and
the bad experiences with higher
education and turn it into motivation to
save even more aggressively for the 529
you know help set your kids up for
success have them
give that savings to them so that they
have it available plus inspire them to
go for scholarships like you said and be
really motivation motivated to own their
own journey to higher education yeah
you're right the the the 450 000 in
debt should lead you the other way to
make you into a savings maniac right
right that is sisterhead so
yeah uh but i guess he just he's
paranoid about the whole
process now i get that i understand that
that's why i'm addressing it but yeah i
think there's very little downside
and um you know
and i do think there's a huge value to a
usable four-year degree
i i you know all three of my kids
four-year degrees sharon and i four-year
degrees
um you know my
uh father-in-law is very very proud that
of his 13 grandkids 12 of them have
four-year degrees you know he's very
proud of that and he should be he should
be that's very good you know and so um
uh
but but but again we're not for useless
degrees we're certainly not for student
loan debt
but uh but none of that's necessary so
all of that to say
we had college funds
and we told our kids from the time they
were little this is your college fund
this is your college fund this is your
college fund which presupposes that by
god you're going to college right you
know it's kind of like drilled in it's
like a little bit of a brainwashing
thing here you know so
yeah so i didn't have i wasn't wringing
my hands that they might not go because
i really wasn't giving them a choice
so i'm but i'm an old school dad that
way so that's the way that works
hey good stuff good stuff thank you for
calling us grace that's a good question
i like talking about it